Every decision we ever make
chaos soon come
Welcome back everyone it's charlie this is going
to be my new venom 2 video for the toxin character
a lot of you saw that big toxin teaser that
they're setting up during the venom 2 movie
so we'll break it all down there's a whole bunch
of easter eggs and obviously this is all heading
in a very specific direction if you're brand new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos there's going to be a lot of venom
stuff happening in the next couple of months
the movie's coming out in september many many
spider-man related movies coming in the next year
between spider-man 3 no way home and the morbius
movie also spider-man into the spider-verse 2.
but during the venom 2 trailer this week it
was revealed that stephen graham this actor
here who some of you may recognize from the many
many british shows that he's been on or some of
the larger movies he was confirmed to be someone
that they're referring to as detective mulligan so
long time venom and carnage comic book fans
freaked out because detective mulligan is
patrick mulligan aka the toxin character from the
comics if you're not a big comic book reader he's
the next symbiote to spawn from venom's line and
he's even more powerful than venom and carnage
put together so in the way that venom spawns the
carnage symbiote and he bonds to cletus cassidy
carnage spawns the toxin symbiote he bonds to
patrick mulligan so steven graham's character is a
much bigger part of their marvel spider-man world
building in all these venom movies than you would
have thought of when they first announced that
he was joining the movie when they first cast him
they didn't say what he was doing or who he was
playing but just talking about their grand plan
for what they're building up to you may remember
a couple years ago when the first venom movie came
out before they'd officially announced any plans
for crossing over venom with tom holland's mcu
spider-man everyone asks will you do carnage
next will you do the other major symbiotes
this is the video clip of them talking about
doing every single one of the major iterations
of the venom symbiote and when i say iterations
of venom they're talking about all the symbiotes
that marvel introduced in the comics after they
introduced the concept of the venom symbiote
one of i think our great hopes for future films is
other articulations of venom so when the producers
say that they're trying to do all the major
versions of the symbiotes eventually as you
see carnage in the venom 2 trailer and then you
see them introduce the detective character called
patrick mulligan it's them just executing that
plan like oh clearly we're going to be doing toxin
next i think we all expected this eventually but
because they killed off all the other symbiotes
in the first venom movie and they were changing
the venom origin story at least so we believed
most of us were just waiting to see how close
to the comic story this would all wind up being
i think a lot of their problems and issues with
that were solved when sony and marvel made their
new deal for sharing tom hall and spider-man and
doing the new spider-man movies now per that deal
sony can reference pretty much anything they want
from the mcu movies that's why you're seeing all
this daily bugle stuff happening during this even
though it's the tobey maguire daily bugle logo so
even though it seems a little bit weird they'll
probably fix a lot of that stuff before venom
2 comes out in theaters they don't have to tiptoe
around the concept of spider-man anymore and even
though i did include that clip in my trailer video
i posted yesterday of andy serkis the director
talking about the way they treated the tom holland
spider-man character the way he says that they
approached it at least at the beginning of this
film is that when the events of the movie pick up
neither eddie brock carnage or any of the other
big characters are aware that spider-man exists so
that does raise some questions about the timeline
and the way they're treating this relative to the
mcu movies i think it's helpful to think of it
in a multiverse context but i think because they
want to use tom hall and spider-man and they
want it to be the same version of spider-man
that's experiencing all these things across the
multiverse or the spider-verse however you want to
think about it i think they're trying to say that
tom hall and spider-man will become the spider-man
of this earth although because sony wants to do
as many spin-offs as possible we could see any
future versions of spider-man wind up inhabiting
this version of earth there's so many versions of
spider-man i am sure sony wants to do every single
one of them the other bonus too is that they just
got done doing some really solid work with the
venom character inside the marvel universe if
you haven't been reading the venom comics the past
few years donnie cates has actually been trying to
take the venom character to a very cosmic avengers
end game type of place that's separate from peter
parker spider-man like spider-man will always
be part of venom's story they're fundamentally
linked as characters but they've been trying to do
really cool venom stories that don't necessarily
depend on spider-man that was what the whole
no god of the symbiote storyline was about
the toxin character is another example of that his
origin story does involve the spider-man character
but because toxin is the spawn of carnage and
patrick mulligan is its host it has this crazy
relationship with venom and carnage because venom
is kind of like its grandfather so they're like
this weird dysfunctional family that you can do
without having to do a ton of spider-man like you
could do a really good toxin story without having
to include tom hall and spider-man at every turn
that being said it does sound like sony is
planning for more tom hall and spider-man
crossover not less as they go along like the
crossovers will only escalate as they do more
movies just based on the talks and easter eggs and
the trailer footage here what it seems like sony
might wind up doing is building up to a version of
the spider-man maximum carnage storyline and just
change it so that it's not just spider-man and
venom teaming up to stop carnage it's both tom
hall and spider-man and tom hardy's venom both the
toms teaming up to fight both carnage and toxin
like toxin becomes one of the new villains
of venom 3 theoretically although there
are some big twists with toxins character that
differentiate it from the carnage symbiote like
they're fundamentally different symbiotes even
though he's the spawn of carnage so i'll explain
that in a second mulligan's scenes in the trailer
make it seem like he was one of the detectives who
was initially responsible for arresting cletus
cassidy when he was first locked up during the
events of the first venom movie but in the trailer
they show this article in the daily bugle that may
be from eddie brock it's not clear who wrote the
article about all these hidden victims of cletus
cassidy that were never found like he killed
way more people and then they arrested him but
they never found the bodies and it just seems like
patrick mulligan is really pissed off about that
and you have eddie going around trying to
assemble this article to find out where the
bodies are hidden in andy circus the director did
his own commentary on the trailer footage and sort
of clarified what's going on between eddie and
cletus when the movie picks up he says the cletus
will only talk to eddie brock about this missing
bodies case so he begins to visit him frequently
in prison setting up their relationship it is
cletus narrates the trailer you can tell he's
kind of obsessed with eddie and begins sending
him handwritten notes written in his blood
that's actually his blood that he's using to
write those so when he's touching it because the
symbiote is bonded to him that means the symbiote
is ingesting some of cletus cassidy's blood which
sort of sets the stage helps foreshadow the
creation of the carnage symbiote and it bonding
with cletus cassidy even though we don't really
see that happen during the trailer footage you
just see it sort of bursting out manifesting
from him when they have him on death row
trying to execute him they use that one as the
loneliest number song and cletus's speech about
leaving things behind so everyone is thinking that
that's a teaser for the venom symbiote spawning
while he's in prison then the carnage symbiote
gets left behind and winds up bonding to cletus
cassidy and that's probably their way of doing
the classic carnage origin story from the comics
but also because of all the toxin easter eggs one
is the loneliest number two can be as bad as one
music could also be a reference to foreshadowing
the eventual carnage symbiote spawning the toxin
symbiote and him becoming just as big a problem
as carnage if not more than venom having to deal
with two of them instead of just carnage although
the relationship between those three symbiotes is
very complicated also that two can be as bad as
one song is meant to be a reference for carnage's
girlfriend shriek in ravencroft here she has this
sonic scream ability that makes her very powerful
against the symbiotes because how do you hurt the
symbiotes you use certain sonic frequencies that's
why spider-man uses the church bells to get rid of
the symbiote during the classic venom origin story
but toxin's history is that he's a relatively
new character he wasn't introduced till 2004
during a venom vs carnage storyline so circle
of life the carnage symbiote realizes that it
had been pregnant and was about to spawn another
symbiote but it hated the idea of toxin before
it was ever born because it was his prophecy
that the thousandth iteration of their lineage
the toxin symbiote would become way more powerful
than any of them before so carnage hates the idea
of toxin even more than it hates venom what
a happy family because you have to remember
that venom is kind of like toxin's grandfather it
made a plan to kill toxin as soon as it spawned
so it's like killing your child right after it's
born but the spawning process left him so weak
that he couldn't do anything about it but because
patrick mulligan just happens to be nearby it puts
the toxin symbiote into him as sort of a temporary
holding vessel saying that he'll come back when
he regains his strength to kill both of them so
carnage didn't give mulligan the toxin symbiote
because he cared about him or he trusted him he
was using him more like a tool like a plaything
then when carnage does become strong enough a
bunch of other characters stop him from killing
toxin venom actually stops him hoping that he can
train toxin to fight spider-man and carnage he's
also responsible for naming the new symbiote toxin
he calls him toxin because his symbiote smells
poisonous to the other symbiotes but he has all
their abilities just turned up to 11. so he can
do all the same things that carnage can do that
venom can do but just more later it's revealed
that mulligan has a strong enough personality and
sense of morality to show carnage mercy when they
fight so venom and carnage then realized that it's
possible toxin could eventually turn good and team
up with spider-man against them which obviously
they don't want so then venom and carnage try to
team up to kill toxin like i said those three
symbiotes relationship is very complicated
eventually peter parker spider-man does help
toxin during the fight realizing what's going on
and then gives mulligan the same version of the
uncle ben's speech with great power comes great
responsibility in mulligan walks away spending his
early days as toxin trying to teach the symbiote
how to be good it's a little bit what you saw
at the end of the first venom movie with eddie
trying to teach the venom symbiote how to be
good the difference is that the toxin symbiote
is essentially a child like it's a newborn child
remember vision in avengers age of ultron when he
was joking about being born yesterday he's kind
of like a child but also a god at the same time
that's basically what the toxin symbiote is it's
not a god it's just way more powerful than both
venom and carnage put together so mulligan spends
most of his time fighting the toxin symbiose baser
urges to just go completely crazy on everyone so
if you're a big fan of steven graham it does sound
like they will eventually try to do the toxin
origin story i don't know how close it'll be
to the comics but hopefully they'll include some
big easter eggs and we'll see some tom hall and
spider-man in there but as it seems like they're
building up to a maximum carnage crossover story
line with tom hall and spider-man they might save
his origin story for that movie if that's going to
be venom 3 or a future movie after that there were
a lot of you i saw that had theories about venom
and carnage teaming up in a future movie against
toxin they could always wind up doing that as well
because i think the whole idea is they want to
keep the carnage character around because he
just serves as a really good villain to contrast
the venom character against if venom's gonna be an
anti-hero you need somebody that's even worse and
that is the carnage character through and through
we'll get more venom two trailers in the next
couple of months so hopefully they'll give us
some more footage of the mulligan character
and if we see any more toxin easter eggs or
easter eggs for other symbiotes and storylines
or even tom hall and spiderman easter eggs of
course i'll do videos for that stuff but if
you have any questions about toxin or the
other symbiotes or big tom hall and spiderman
crossover just leave them in the comments below
there's a whole bunch of marvel stuff coming up my
marvel loki episodes will start posting soon in a
couple weeks so make sure you have alerts enabled
so you don't miss any of those everyone click here
for my full venom 2 trailer video and click here
for my brand new marvel phase 4 trailer video and
eternals trailer thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe i'll see you guys tonight!